so i think now you know we're seeing
this surges of people who are really
young coming out as non-binary or gay or
or trans and i think straight people are
viewing that as like
this is too much and this is i'm just
like no we just finally have people can
finally see themselves at a young age
yeah and and can relate to that which i
i had c-3po i mean i had like
nothing i had like that was it i had i
don't know
i had jafar i had a car
these are gay icons that's the gay
people i saw on tv
okay no it makes so much sense
first of all he's gay right and
i've done this a bit because like he got
gay or needs star wars movie like the
first one he's very
subtle he's just like oh my but then
like
by return of the jedi at one point he's
literally like stay alone
and r2d2 is a lesbian she's a full-blown
lesbian she's smart people need her and
she came with the tool belt also
like most lesbians she gets [ __ ] done
when the millennium falcon breaks down
they're not calling 3po they're like r2
get in here three people got the ladder
at the nightclub
she did she did yes that is right
but then you know jafar who's like very
gay
gay i see it is jafar
sure yeah um ursula
um ursula's lesbian uh drag
oh she was based after a real drag queen
named divine
who was very i've heard of devon of
course she was very popular in the 80s
yeah yeah
yeah so so this is okay keep going on
this because then i want to talk about
rupaul's drag quest because you said the
most interesting thing about drag race
i've ever heard oh what did i say
you're like it's the first time a a a
gay show was made for gay people
yes i would say you know it wasn't
trying to like
create this idea of homosexuality for
straight people right queer eye or
something
yeah queer eyes like exactly like what
is queer eye um
it's a it's a television series
you got to be polite and they're
offering me a role
i wish i would be so horrible on that
show though because they're so nice and
they want to like be together and work
together
i've met i've met a lot of them in the
first part of the show though this [ __ ]
me they just go through the guy's stuff
and just [ __ ] on all of it they just
bully this guy
who would wear such a thing but that's
the role for gay people in television
for like the last 50 years yeah
well yeah and also too like the first
iteration of the show was the first time
you saw gay people in living rooms that
weren't like
you know philadelphia you know what i
mean like it was like
something because people you know what i
mean it was like something
nice kind of yeah even though we were
like middle america's like where's the
bruises
right these guys but we were a little
like captain planet of gays like at that
you know remember captain planet they
had like all their ring like earth fire
they were like purse you know but um
but it was good i love cars like that
was a it was a great show but then
you know as time moved on it's like i
think they've adapted the show so that
it's not just like
you know queer people walking and being
like this sucks but it does feel like
we've done
gay people have done everything for you
people and it's like
it's enough all right we've done your
weddings your hair your makeup your
movies and
we're you know we show up in the middle
of indiana and this lady's like my
husband can't put his pants on like
is that our problem you had years to
know how to do this like
you figure it out that show should be
five gay men on an island smoking being
like we hate you
but yeah but you said drag race oh
so drag race well do you remember where
we were we were leaving some gig or
something like that and like you were
breaking down drag race to me and you're
just like
yeah we love it and i'm like i'm like
why why is this any different you're
like
we're finally not explaining what it is
to be gay
right straight people right we're just
being ourselves
super nuanced like niche jokes that only
we get
and they don't care if nobody else gets
it right and the coolest thing about it
is
it's and again you know don't let me
speak for you here but like it it is
authentic and because it's authentic
the world gravitates to it by not trying
to appease everybody
right by just going this is who we are
all of a sudden that like voyeurism
kicks in
like my fiance loves it her friends love
it yeah and
i think there's something in us which is
like when you actually get to see people
being themselves
enjoying themselves laughing you want to
know what's so fun right
like what's happening well it also i
think it demystifies even for
gay people i mean when i came out back
in my day when i came out
uh i was i was 19 and we i didn't even
know
really what a drag queen was i mean i
knew who rupaul was because of the brady
bunch movie
which is still do you guys remember that
movie no yeah vaguely such a good
there's such a great scene where where
jan's talking to
rupaul who was the school counselor yeah
and
you know she's whatever and then rupaul
at the end she's like jan come back when
you're pregnant i mean
it's a very good movie but i i remember
the first time seeing my
first drag queen because i had not been
exposed to it wasn't on tv
nothing i didn't know what to make of it
i also was at that time i was coming out
of this idea of like
you know femininity being feminine was
bad
and i had to sort of like reject
anything that made me look
gay or this or that you know and that
slowly melts away the more you come to
terms with
who you are and what that is and why
that has nothing to do with you yeah
and so the show when it first started it
was just on logo and it was low budget
and it was just a bunch of drag queens
kind of like a mix of
of uh project runway and america's got
talent
and it's evolved into something that has
meant so much more to a lot of people
so now it's like very popular with white
girls and
um who take over everything yeah and uh
yeah i want to talk about that too
are people having fun we now own it so
um
but no it should be something that you
know should be enjoyed by everybody
but uh yeah that show really helped me
like
melt away my own internalized homophobia
and even the way i tell jokes is
different you know i think i usually
yeah i used to be when i
first started doing comedy on my only
there's i've never seen a gay comedian
on television without like an hour
special ever yes it just hasn't existed
so i had nowhere to look yeah and so i
went to kathy griffin and joan rivers
and margaret cho
they were the ones that were speaking
closest to me
and you know i love kathy griffin and i
love joan rivers but they've said a lot
of
disparaging things about women and other
celebrities and so that was my idea when
i started doing comedy
i was very i have to [ __ ] on misogynist
and
make fun of how people look i mean it's
not humor i
partake in anymore really i also i'm a
better writer like
as you evolve but um hopefully we start
seeing more
gay comics of all varieties so that
other people can
see us that's an interesting thing
though like uh you
you've often seen the fan bases
for gay celebs
be majority female right right
and then the fan base is for female
uh like comedians majority gay
correct can you explain that phenomenon
i think it probably has to do with the
fact i'm sorry if this got so serious
no no we could seriously and then we'll
get we'll get flagrant
okay i think a lot of it probably has to
this is also my experience i hate now
that
nowadays everyone has to take on
everyone else's experience yeah like
it's your experience it's my experience
relax so um i
think maybe part of that has to do with
the look be
like i the idea if you're 19 watching
this you have no
concept really of what it was like in
the 1980s 70s 60s 50s
when you were gay like in the 1960s for
example
when bars were raided by cops it was
illegal to be gay
and not only were they rated but they
took your id
and they posted it on the front of the
new york times so you were fired
immediately whatever your job occupation
was so i
it just took a really long time for
people for this idea of effeminate men
which is not typical to all gay men or
queer people but that was the stereotype
to sort of be accepted in entertainment
and
i think um i think we
gay men saw themselves in these
extravagant women
by the liza minnelli's the barbra
streisands the
the women that were out of the mold so
to speak and made it
yeah yeah yeah because there was no
example of like who they were so the
closest example of who they wanted to be
maleficent yeah
that was a horn we were like god i love
her like that is
[Applause]
you